both of you are default bald guide the
same are we ever going to be underwear
you can choose to be only an
underwear
wa how is this happen is he getting
fatter oh yes oh wow he's actually just
getting fatter work smile wa an
artist go G ghost ghost I saw it I got a
picture of it get the pictures oh oh oh
oh oh
picture I'm done I'm done so can I get a
res I'm going draw another the card Mark
and this one will save you I one called
aggressive I'm going to go stand outside
for a minute is it hunting no the front
door is open so oh wait I have bad news
about the front door being open I'm
going to try and draw another card no
hey the door the door is open I'm
drawing a card wait this one all right
this will help oh my I'm Full Speed
Ahead baby got it hey I did it hey you
did it I knew I could do it how do I how
do I get out of here uh back to the safe
house with my success in hand damn where
do I look at the
pictures uh where's the
pictures that didn't even get me past
level one I'm still level one after that
I'm actually kind of surprised by that
and I don't know where the pictures are
do they not maybe they don't see I'm 3
XP short of leveling up are you joking
me should I buy some stuff with how much
money do you have 3900 Smacker rooies
damn you got so much money cuz I lived
and am a genius oh I mean yeah you can
buy whatever you want to I have
everything except for sanity pills that
I can add oh I'll buy some drugs these
things are so expensive I know no you're
just broke mark That's why death really
sucked for for me cuz I didn't have any
money and now I've got even less than I
did what but then how are you even
supposed to find a ghost if you don't
have anything well it gives you the
basic off with uh you start with the
what EMF ESG flashlight an easel an Ecto
Spirit box and a UV light you just don't
have any of the protection items a
crucifix is $2,000 two pieces of wood
four Nails yep tell me about it man I
just bought two of them that was all my
money well that sounds like a waste of
money we are fine I used two of them to
save us we were all we made it just
saying you and I literally died we did
not well why am I
alive he's skinny again wow yeah he's
malnourished Mark we need to take care
of the cat the
game I will vomit into this plate uh
Mark you going to ready up or uh oh no
um ready well the bad news is we
currently only have two sanity pills me
three of us but you know we'll make it
work oh I could add one more I own one
more there we go we go I can't afford
anything excellent ooh here we go the
Deep
base whoa welcome to the Deadwood house
all right I know what to
do all right flashlight I got my where's
my
camera we couldn't afford another one we
don't have one what do you mean b
brought it back I did have it in my
inventory a I I didn't see oh whatever
you know what mark That's not me that's
on all right thank you all right I don't
need it who needs it not me just Mark
just take mental pictures okay sounds
good uh click nice
Moon oh what's that that's a
door no the sound it's a fly oh that was
a different sound
oh all right dibs on the top
bunk sure sure don't don't laugh like
that ever again
oh what's up man um you all right I just
had a little goofy in me and I got it
out a musical instrument there was a
fellow in a suit with a red tie and a
and a blank white face is that is slend
probably bad oh no that's just Wade oh
that's Wade here I'm just
piano that was
nicey there's a lot of Ouija board guys
oh snap oh that's very good
yep go we got we got to EG Mark I'm
going to eg it up right by the
Yano UV light crap how do I we it just
opened a door near me how do I ask it a
question honestly never used p in this
game as far as I remember so I don't
know how many pickles can you shoot
shove up your
ass you hear that scraping Mark nope
it's like in
here yeah
oh oh that's probably fine yeah probably
fine I don't see anything ceiling Decor
oh
EMF well probably not in there is way
dead already no I went to get the UV
light cuz the door's opening and closing
I thought might reveal a fingerprint or
something h h did you oh the the bed is
cracky SMI smacky EMF of 3.0 in the in
the bedroom back here where you're where
you dropped your thermometer oh okay
where oh this way all right over here
follow the sound of my
voice oh look at that big old handprint
hand print awesome all right dropping
this in here that's not how you use door
knobs plopping the Ouija board down why
are you so
dumb
um oh oh oh oh oh he's so big I mean
look that's not the only thing I noticed
okay
so um how stupidly was your
death that's not doing anything wait
seems like a bust you what's your
name Isaac or no what's his name Ezekiel
what's your
name you have a free hand to use it I
don't know that's not the hello what is
your name Ezekiel do you need the box to
talk to him or what you can what you
just okay no one's going to do the okay
I don't know what you're talking about
but it's funny I laugh no one's no one's
going to be my Tony what do you mean
what are you talking about [__] you
Ezekiel [__] you Tony I I don't know
what's happening I you guys don't know
that Meme no all right everyone in the
oh well all right I just turned that
on everyone everyone in the oh EMF oh
bad bad bed bed Clank
Clank somebody's really trying to get us
in bed mark yeah I love the razor sheets
I guess I'm going to leave the
thermometer here I'm going to go try to
get the uh easel whatever else we might
need I don't know what else Spirit Box
get the Spirit Box oh okay I'll get
Spirit box someone else needs to come
get the easel then I'm coming I'll stay
here alone Mark keep him Company Mark
yep hey if this bed's rocking when you
come
back uh it was already what do you mark
don't [__] the
ghost what whatever happens I can't
believe that's something I have to say
to you whatever happens happens I'm not
going to limit what you can or cannot do
Mark I think you should follow I think
you should follow your instincts my only
my body knows its true limits and I have
yet to find them our sanity is okay not
bad sanity you okay sanity you okay okay
San that one didn't
work not it was a good whoa what are you
doing what do you mean I know Andrew
Tate's walking backwards in front front
of me going wiggle wle wible wobble
don't be that man come
on what that is that not on purpose I
thought you were trying to be the
actually yeah I'm more like pit bull
remember remember pit this are worldwide
Mark what are you doing here huh what do
you mean oh oh you're just sliding
buckets also okay I see my breath Chile
hi welcome to chili freezing temps again
we got freezing temps again hi hi okay
it cannot be ESG this time that's the
one we can roll out all right how do I
get the IGI I don't I don't know where
are you huh right here what do you want
ghost do you think I'm
pretty super and flopsy and all Spirit
boxy tell me your name or live in
shame it's not talking to
[Laughter]
me Mark why is there barbed wire on the
bed I don't think that was there when we
left was it yes it was I I commented
nice razor sheets they should call you
Mr
observant what are you
wearing did I turn off my like
microphone in the game maybe it likes
you more all right probably everything
likes me more how do I use it just left
what's up how's it doing uh give me a
number through one through zero two not
you oh rumors say that you're a little
bit ugly can can you confirm or deny hey
can you uh give me a sign or
something where is the EMF at is that in
the room I'm carrying it around
unfortunately you hey uh you know what
I'm actually seeing something hey Mark
hold still yep what's up seeing some
stains here what do you mean oh is that
what we're looking for wait or um I
closer you if I want to confirm but if
you drop that I can take a
look well not that I just dropped the
EMF somewhere oh oh at least it moved
the bucket back D ghost moves some stuff
around the room says what or does that
it's only EMF of three got to be honest
very disappointing uh give me a yes or
no
answer ooh kir clunk over here klunk
HH um sounds good that's probably
fine I love you can we go up is there
upstairs in this not I know of but I'm
not going to lie this is the newer map
so I've only been here I feel like that
was upstairs but I haven't seen stairs
or anything yeah I don't think there was
oh ghost ghost spear box did something
it did something ohing me spear
box it's a
gal all right I'm going to go outside's
the other oh we also had fingerprint huh
oh okay yep it's a goal it's a
goal
goal yeah
you're a
go I didn't get what you were doing for
an embarrassingly long amount of time oh
oh I get it thanks I thought was no I I
got there I got there okay oh hey we
might as well just leave and take our
win why why because the top objective in
the next section is take a solid photo
of The Ghost and you know without a
camera I don't think we're doing that ah
Mark what do you mean it might give us
some bonus money if we get it to blow
out a candle and also find it with the
ectoplasm do we have a candle you know
maybe we just take
the what do you mean all right boys time
to get a what do you mean me we're doing
something together this is a team moment
Mark thanks thanks I'm assuming that's
like a cheerful thing
sure hello go my name is Markiplier wait
did did you go back in yeah why I
thought we were blowing out a candle we
leaving we don't have you you said you
said blow out a candle we don't we
didn't bring one yeah [__] you ghost
yeah [__] you [__] you ghost [__] you
[__] you all right I'm out that might be
a really bad idea with a gold I'm even
I'm not even in it GS get angry in a
hunt if you
swear all right well let's see this
thing [__] [__] ass piss [__] [__] ass
[__] chos [__] [__]
[__] nothing's happening ohy wa wait a
minute wait wait a minute all right okay
well that didn't work well you're also
not in its room you're barely putting a
pinky toe into the door [__] [__] ass
ass
[__] that ghost is getting really mad
come back in here also with the what for
yeah all right well that was nice [__]
yeah
dude that's a lot of money it's not it's
some though I'm level two I'm level one
I'm so good at this game God damn it
yeah eat Kitty eat consume how quick can
we die what if we go in with nothing
well you know I can up the difficulty
yeah Crank It Up to Max I just want to
see how quick we can die I want to piss
off this ghost I know we haven't even
died yet
yeah cuz it gives us BAS stuff right it
gives us freebies right I don't know if
we'll each have a flashlight but we'll
have something I don't need one Bob did
you add a flashlight cuz it says two a
four you might want to remove it if
we're just going to go in and die I have
not added anything I don't know
interesting that we have two FL okay
well that's fine Kuro Kur kurogawa
uh Mark since you didn't want a
flashlight you take the UV light that
your flashlight that sounds good detect
the type of ghost
uh-huh Leslie Marine
I'll curse at it [__] you [__] you [__]
you [__] you [__] you [__] you [__] you
[__] you [__] you I'm flicking your
lights [__] you I'm driving up your
power bill [__] you really getting under
the skin of this ghost Mark you be the
worst on an actual Ghost
Hunt ah what's this a little doll what
this a stupid little doll [__] you I
found a doll vo doll yeah what does it
do it using it Mark touch it uhoh oh huh
um everyone else hearing that breathing
oh
okay yoink I did
it hey bark what's up cool doll thanks
it's uh it got Nails in it oh sick where
you guys at just down uh EMF is having a
spazzle oh oh you're floating oh uh oh
uhoh uhoh oh boy
oh [__] you you push the through the
yeah I did yeah okay that
explains that explains that is that you
Bob also Bob your CR is
stainless stainless yeah unlike Mars oh
okay anyway you think you you're tough
just cuz you killed my friend [__] you
Wimpy couldn't get me ah [__] you did we
even ever see it I saw it kill me yeah
but did you see it like run at you or
did it come from behind you no I saw the
death cut scene and that's about it
777 well yeah got him we've got power of
God and enemy on our side yeah take this
and that all right Naruto [__] you that
was do the ghost not you did Mark get me
killed with the doll is that what yeah
100% oh okay I don't know if that's
verifiable I mean you pushed the pen
through the voodoo doll's heart and
triggered a hunt and then Bob died yeah
but I mean what was the point what's the
point of that item then I'm by you Mark
hey what's up I think you can make the
ghost interact a light just exploded in
here I know I know I don't have a
flashlight so I can't
see hey wa they really don't want to
keep the lights how are you I'm good I'm
good all right did anyone pick up my EMF
reader and my easel and my flashlight uh
can't see I have some good stuff no I'll
grab the
flashlight oh hey there's an upstairs
guys did you do everyone see that yeah
that's where I was when the hunt started
oh cool it's pretty small but it does
exist yeah there's not kind of like Mar
penis there's a clock up here if if we
end up me that I I hold on one second uh
I don't know what you've heard rumors
about my penis it is Extreme is it is um
cumbersome it's cumbersome it's
cumbersome I imagine it would be
cumbersome to have such a small penis no
no that uh ghost don't listen to him
it's the opposite reason for the
cumbersome around this like magnifying
glass ghost why do why do you want to
look at why do you want to why why not
that it's would be necessary for it but
why would you want to look H
science I'm a scientist man not a doctor
fine this is not much ghosting happening
yeah I feel like took the full brunt of
the ghost so far and nothing else has
even really happened what was that oh
please there's just some Han Zimmer in
the distance calm down well you know I'm
in a dark room holding a cockroach so
things are oh maybe if you stop playing
with yourself and started focusing we
can find this ghost I don't I can't
believe we didn't even see it hunt you
you just died yeah I did I did that's a
new one for me I mean we always see it
coming this doesn't this place doesn't
seem very big I can't find any other
spots yeah I feel like there is a ghost
here it's really well hidden like it's
it's really trying not to interact with
us H is that an attribute of a ghost
that helps us shade maybe oh there's a
demon child what do you mean that's
probably ghost related
yeah where you at [__] you [__] you [__]
you I'm in the room with the
statues you see it you see I saw demony
oh hey what's up guys [__] you I want to
see
A2 oh oh you think
it's hey man this thing all of a sudden
is a lot more ghostly I think it's in
here I'll go get the easel man I got to
go a long way I don't think it's
responding to the Spirit Box so I'm
going to lose that um the lights are on
in this room I think the lights have to
be off right to talk to the Spirit Box
what do that mean I just heard it talk
are you guys hearing it talk uh yeah not
through spear box up to EMF 3 and I
think I see my breath which I imagine is
freezing freezing so I'm just going to
guess freezing I feel like I'm not
really helping very much I got to be
honest well it's all right you're doing
great I'll just drag all this stuff over
Bob honestly you're winning the goal was
to see how fast we could die and you
really took it to heart that's
true oh hey look there's those things
again okay all right I got to go back
get the spear box just in case that's
probably a good idea I'll watch the pile
of gear don't worry guys okay I'm
tripping on drugs all right oh the light
the light switch in here is CL clunk a
clunk a clunk do I need the UV light do
I need the UV yeah that' be for
fingerprints yeah okay grabbing UV oh hi
oh no hey guys that seems bad oh the
demon child is in here oh means it's
hunting it's it's doing stuff it's
coming out it's going out of the room
now bye why would it be doing that I
don't I don't I don't know oh
oh I got second
well I was the one cursing it out this
whole time it's not even going to come
after me apparently not God damn it all
right listen here you little [__] you
think you can kill my friends and get
away with it [__] you go oh
NE did you capture that Mark I did not
how what evidence do I do I don't see
anything on the eil I don't see anything
on anything temperatures maybe let me
look around with the oh I don't have
have it oh yes I do
fingerprints fingerprints be a hard room
to get oh wait did it draw in the easel
is that a drawing oh wait oh it's a
drawing that's new oh cool that's new
that's nice Revenant Hato demon or may
may I'm behind you I heard that you're
behind me um oh got a four I'll just go
ahead and say five Revenant are unstable
and unpredictable uh-huh May are
difficult to detect but there's someone
nearby it will not want to hunt so I
don't think it's a m cuz we were
together okay so it's not EMF level 5 or
no wait it went to four it didn't do
anything yeah it can't it's notf or
ESG fingerprint stains or Spirit Box I
don't know it's not Spirit boxing did
you turn the lights off in the room what
is your
oh oh you're dead oh it it didn't like
that Mark whatever you just did oh
hey oh
ooh turn your leg around you you
mean you
me the goddamn hokey pokei I wasn't
ready I hope hope my real death has you
laughing into the eternity as the ghost
was the be the thing that we ruled out I
know I didn't rule it out I I said it
was probably going to be MF level 5 I
was ready to check that off and bolt
well we were together whenever I got
murdered weren't we no no we started
hunting I mean when I when I died I was
right next to Mark before I he he forced
the hunt with the voodoo doll that one's
different
oh he and I were together when it hunted
the next time ah okay all right well
that was fun I'm glad you all enjoyed um
uh uh
demon so you had an echo the whole time
yeah I don't have an echo everyone
should listen to distractable watch
distractable yes distractable yes
Spotify it's a
good I can't I don't have that set up
right now I don't come
on just just fake it fake an echo I
was do it
better
it's like he's here
[Music]
with